[Music]
jared is with us in minneapolis hi jared
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave how are you doing better than i
deserve what's up
well we have um completed most of the
baby steps we are
now max funding 15
between our roth 401k through work and
our roth ira
um and we have some money my wife needs
a new car our household income is a
hundred and sixty thousand dollars a
year
um and we are ready to pay about twenty
five thousand dollars cash for a new car
for her good
however that being said the used car
market is ridiculous right now agreed
and
for example i just out of curiosity put
in an order on a ford pickup truck it's
like the little ford maverick
i built that for 22 grand
and it's going for 35 grand used on the
used market right now
so i'm just wondering
um
are we in a situation where it might be
acceptable to buy new if you've got the
cash for it rather than buy used
because i'm going to reap several
benefits just from warranties it never
being driven by somebody else
and all that
yeah i mean the reason for
our no new car
rule before you have a million dollar
net worth it's because you can't take
the hit when you drive it off the lot
right how much it loses in value
but now it's the only time i can
remember so i'll be so curious
that no and you're right jared my
husband and i we were looking for a new
car and we even kelly blue booked our
van we bought a new van in 2019 we can
sell it today
for two thousand dollars more than what
we paid for it in 2019. like
it's bizarre so
in my opinion i mean if it's if it's
cheaper but can you get the truck though
that's the thing is that we're looking
at it you're not going to get that truck
dude well it'll take four months it has
a build data april 18th yeah it has a
bill date but you haven't talked to the
dealer yet about how much they're going
to market up above msrp
because yeah there's
dumping on these msrps all over the
place just make sure you get solid
numbers though but here's the deal
writing
you have it in writing and writing
something they're not going to do that
which uh
i'll contest as they do
even if they do bump it up i'd
still be worth less than
what it would be used yeah so what's
your net worth
uh probably a hundred thousand dollars
right now we're both 24.
we are debt-free so here's the thing
you know you can do this here's the
danger if you do it
all right the danger is number one i
don't think that this is gonna fly i
don't think it's gonna work because the
all the people i'm talking to in the car
business are marking up everything
and so i don't know that you're gonna
take delivery on this like you think
you're going to you might
it might you might pull it off
um in which case you could sell it the
next day for a ten thousand dollar
profit
and so that just sounds a little whack
to me doesn't it to you
you know generally speaking in my life
if something sounds too good to be true
it's because it is
so that's the problem that bothers me
here the second thing is this
i don't want you to get in the habit of
asking the wrong question
right and the wrong question is how can
i figure out a way
to
violate a proven system towards wealth
and still be okay because i want a truck
you know
okay so no seriously this is this is a
problem you know i don't know if i
agreed to i don't know hold on jared
needs a new car
jared sees a used car i i
it's it's still the wrong question for
20 no if i need a new car one cost me 26
thousand and a new one cost me twenty
two thousand and i have a letter which
that may be off not real whatever
we'll see
but to me it's math like the reason the
new car
principle is math like what happened
three years five years from today what
happens 30 years from today
to jared if he keeps asking questions
that he's trying to figure out a way to
make everything okay that he wants to do
i don't think he this is this i know but
this rationalization process that people
use is what gets them in trouble okay so
here's a good
cars go down in value
don't buy expensive cars when you're
broke and 24 years old you know
don't do it you know but expensive car
though
is by the number though i understand but
i there's a reason that for 30 years
i've taught people not to buy new cars
until they have a million dollar net
worth there's a reason and the reason is
and they're because they go down in
value like a rock so do the used cars
and and if you buy a 35 so my advice
would be completely different my advice
would be don't buy a car right now
it's a horrible time to buy a car oh no
it's a horrible time to buy a car answer
c so we didn't even go there
i've got the money to absorb the blow
and my net worth is considerably more
than a million dollars but if i was
getting ready to buy a car it wouldn't
be this year
i'm gonna drive what i got and let this
crap work its way out
okay but what if for people listening
though because i literally one of one of
my friends who you know her van got like
it they took it and they were like
yes because the materials and the subs
and the gcs are nuts totally i know but
if jared had to buy a car though what
would you say that if he was homeless
i'd tell him build a house
if he had to buy a car a time buy a car
and buy a new car you didn't answer it i
really wouldn't you would get the 26
thousand dollar used one i cuz number
one i am just i'm not buying the premise
that it's all gonna work out okay
because i mean
i was with a guy the other day
on the lot looking at a hundred and four
thousand dollars you weren't gonna buy a
new one i did i said i i didn't say i
was buying it i was with a guy okay 104
000 car that you can't find yeah and
they're brand new and you can't find
them they're short on inventory like all
cars are you know what they're selling
it for 140 000 brand new they marked it
up 36 000 over msrp the dealer did on a
brand new vehicle that was sitting in
the lot right there yeah
and i don't care if it's a build order
or not it's going to land on the dadgum
lot yeah and that dealer and can only
get so many of each allocation of each
vehicle and that they can mark them up
30 000 or they can sell you want it what
you built it on the web for i ain't
buying it i know but what is that thing
but what is it though when you can build
it online and buy it how do they like i
don't
listen i'm just telling you the pressure
is out there right now and until the
pressure subsides
you're gonna have to be careful yes you
have to be careful and and don't get in
the habit of
trying to figure out a way
to do things
that that are perpendicular to what you
know to be true
yeah that's a bad habit to put yourself
in there it's a bad question to ask
in that sense i'm not saying him asking
the question was invalid i appreciate
the discussion i like talking about it
arguing with you about it but the uh i'm
here god's sakes but but the uh uh you
know that that's the thing i just you
know it's a it's all it's a whacked
world right now
horrible time to buy a car